لا تهداوا التظاهرات الايرانيه في المانيا
التي تطالب الحكومه بالتشدد اكثر مع طهران
ومنذ ان بدات التظاهرات في ايران والعلاقه
بين برلين وطهران تحولت الى ماده جدلا
سياسيا هنا حزب المعارضه الرئيسي المسيح
الديمقراطي الذي تنتمي اليه المستشاره
السابقه انجيل ميركل لم يتردد باتهام
الحكومه باعتماد سياسه لينه مع طهران خلال
جلسه صوت فيها النواب للتبني ورقه تطالب
الحكومه بالتشدد اكثر مع ايران والنائب و
كريستيانو
حتى ان الوقت لم يعد مناسبا للابقاء على
الحوار مفتوحا مع طهران والتمسك بالاتفاق
النووي
دفعت بسياسه المهدنه اتجاه ايران كانت
هناك مطالبات واضحه من الليبراليين مثلا
لاغلاق مركز الاسلامي ولكن حزب الخضر لم
يدفع بالامر رغم ان كل الحقائق على طاوله
موجوده والمركز المراقب من المخابرات منذ
30 عاما
ليس بهذه السهوله يقول الرئيس السابق
للمخابرات الالمانيه او كستانينج الذي كان
جهازه يراقب مركزه همبرج منذ ان كان هو
رئيسه بين العامين
1998 و25 بسبب نشاطاته المشوهه
يمكن ان يمارس ديانته بحريه ولهذا نفصل
بين الدين
من حظر تجمعات الدينيه ولكن عندما تستخدم
الديانات اداه سياسيه او للتحريض على
العنف فهذا خط احمر
بحقوق الانسان
الحكومه الالمانيه ترفض انتقادات المعارضه
وتؤكد ان مقاربتها لايران صحيحه فهي تريد
معاقبه النظام الايراني لتصديه للمتظاهرين
ولكنها تبقى حريصه على ابقاء باب الحوار
مفتوحا خاصه فيما يتعلق بالملف النووي
العربيه برلين